In this video I want to help you
to gain experience by building an important skill -
seeing some algebraic calculations that are made,
to be able to judge if they are true.
This is a very valuable skill.
You can check the work of other people,
you can check your own work, say:
"Did I do it right?"
"Does my logic support the verification?"
"Why do not I get the answer,
who do I think I should get? "
Let's get some experience with this.
I have one equation,
nine in and then in brackets,
2x plus 1/3 equals 39.
And someone has decided it.
This is step one, step two, and finally step three.
This solution was obtained: x equal to two.
Pause the video now
and try to find out if this solution is right.
Whether all the steps that have been made are logical,
whether they have algebraic meaning?
Or is there a mistake in any of these steps,
and if so, in which of these steps was an error occurred?
Now let's go through this task,
to see if all these steps have logic.
In the first step, 18x,
it seems that brackets have been revealed.
Nine in two x will be 18x and then of course
you will also have to calculate nine by one third.
Nine per 1/3 will be 9/3 or three,
this also seems acceptable.
And you got 39 here on the right.
Therefore, step one is verified.
Now, let's see what they did here?
After step one, or at this stage,
we have 18x plus three,
then we only have 18x here.
They must have pulled three
on the left side to get rid of it.
They took three on the left side.
But if they pull out three on the left,
they have to pull out three also on the right side
and they seem to have done so.
39 minus 3 is 36. So this step is checked.
We have 18x equals 36.
To find x,
you will just split the two sides to 18.
You will get x equals 36 on 18 or 2.
We've checked all the steps
and there is no mistake.
And you can check that x is really equal to two.
Let's solve a few more tasks
and see if we can determine whether there are mistakes or not.
We have 8/3 is equal to 3 in "c" plus 5/3
and we want to find "c".
Pause the video and see if there are any errors
and if any of these steps are wrong,
or maybe there are no errors at all.
Let's do it step by step.
In step one left side is left the same.
The right side, let's see ...
We get 3 out of this 3c,
seem to reveal brackets.
Three in "c" is really 3c.
Then we need to multiply 3 by 5/3,
it will be five.
It will not be 5/3.
This thing here should be five,
not 5/3, this is not true.
So we found an error in step one.
Let's continue. Let's do one more of these tasks.
I find this funny.
Okay, this is a bit simpler.
1/4 r plus 2 is equal to 10.
And then they immediately received only 1/4 r,
they are getting rid of this pair on the left side.
Well, to do this, you can pull two left,
but of course you have to do it too
and on the right side.
And you get 1/4 r plus 2 minus two,
this will be only 1/4 r.
Yes, the left side is logical.
10 minus 2 is not 12.
10 minus 2 is eight.
This should be eight.
They added two on the right side.
They took two on the left,
but they have added it to the right.
Then equality will no longer be true.
There is definitely a mistake.
Step one is not true.